hey youtubers it's Charlie so my friends
at geek & sundry are building the ferry
boat from operating of time in real life
and Nintendo totally just showed off the
brand-new footage from Zelda Wii U at e3
so I'm gonna do a breakdown of that
footage as well as my top five items in
the game and some of the lore behind
them just like Final Fantasy the Zelda
games have pretty good continuity when
it comes to in-game items and backstory
there's a few small differences that
we'll talk about for each item though I
also post a link in the description for
the build video so you guys can watch
Nika make the bow in real life so first
things first
Zelda Wii U because Nintendo's super
hardcore about the way you use their
footage on YouTube I'm not gonna post
the actual trailer I'll just post screen
caps when I talk about it the game is
coming in 2015 they didn't specify a
spring or winter but the biggest change
is the mechanics in the way you interact
with the environment obviously the
artwork makes your eyes want to melt out
of their sockets it's gonna be a lot
more like next gen RPG games where
there's a story to follow but there
aren't really any environment boundaries
in the game like previous installments
it's like one continuous world you don't
instance into new areas so the game is
just loading new environments
continuously as you travel obviously
boss fights and encounters have been
changed accordingly as you enter new
areas you'll just randomly encounter
enemies and bosses will have patrol
areas like in MMOs
so let me know if you like that it's
starting to look more like an MMO or if
you prefer that classic mechanics but I
totally love the artwork and I might
have to buy a Wii U now shut up and take
my rupees it all reminds me whenever
Ocarina of Time came out and melted
everyone's brains Ocarina of Time was
the first Zelda game to come out on n64
and I think it hit around Christmas
break from school so everybody that I
knew just disappeared for two weeks into
their basement so they could play
through the whole thing of all the Zelda
titles ocarina of time is still my
favorite to replay so here are my top 5
in-game items as well as some of the
lore behind them number 5 the goddess
harp in the timeline of the franchise
the first time link gets this is in
Skyward Sword as a child but it's also
used by Princess Zelda and Ocarina of
Time and you could argue that it it's
almost the same thing as the harp of
Ages in the Oracle series on gameboy
color in Skyward Sword it functions a
lot like the Ocarina of Time and that it
helps you unlock new challenges in the
game and progress in Ock
of time Zelda only uses the teacher new
ocarina song so in each game the items
get used in slightly different ways even
though the Laure is similar as the name
implies it came from the goddess hylia
she was the guys who stayed behind to
guard the Triforce whenever the old gods
left Hyrule she eventually decided to
take mortal form and then became the
progenitor of the hyrulean royal family
in the franchise she became the first
incarnation of zelda in the Skyward
Sword but for example in ocarina of time
the Zelda we meet is her descendant in
all the games the royal family always
descends from the goddesses bloodline
though I think Ocarina of Time was the
first time we actually met the gods but
each subsequent game continued to
feature them number 4 the silver arrow
next to the Master Sword this is one of
the most important items in the
franchise in the original NES games you
use it to kill Ganon at the end and in
later games in the franchise they just
turned it into the light arrows it's the
same item though it's sort of the same
function and they cause enemies to drop
hella extra rupees in Twilight Princess
you don't actually get to use them but
Zelda does and they serve the same
function in the Lord they're generally
just magical arrows that literally
pierce evil in some of the later games
you actually find them as an item in
dungeons but in ocarina of time Zelda
just gives them to you once you wake all
the sages up that was also one of the
first times we saw the sages but after
that they were incorporated into all
aspects of the franchise they serve as
like the bridge between the sacred realm
where the Triforce is kept and the
physical world of Hyrule on to number
three the magical mirror this only
appears in Link to the Past and you get
to use it to travel between the light in
the dark worlds but you can also use it
as a warp device inside dungeons you
obtain it by helping the lost old man
that's the only name he's given but in
the lore he's a descendant of the sages
and you eventually have to risk who's
daughter who's one of the seven maidens
also a big part of the lore the maidens
are just like a female analog of the
sages in some of the later games you
also learn a lot about the power of the
mirror from sahasrara who's also a
descendant of the sages and helped teach
you things inside Link to the Past if
you were ever a huge fan of Nintendo
Power they actually did a really awesome
integration with length of the past they
incorporated this whole big comic and
story it was a lot of fun number two the
Hylian Shield in the game it's the most
powerful show that you can get and it
protects you from fire usually the
shield is purchased but Skyward Sword
introduced some creative lore around it
it's guarded by the Dragon Leonora who's
one of the three sacred guardians
appointed by the goddess to watch over
parts of Hyrule the shield is most
notable just for its appearance in the
crest all incarnations of the franchise
have used the same base symbols which
incorporate aspects of the goddess crest
the royal crest and the Hylian crest in
ocarina of time it's the Triforce in the
crimson loft wing but Skyward Sword
actually did this really cool thing
where they actually made the loft wing a
real bird that you get to use in that
game you actually get bonded to the loft
wing a lot like Daenerys and Game of
Thrones gets bonded to her dragons and
my number one item of course the Master
Sword I think my favorite animation in
the series is still link yanking the
Master Sword out of the temple of time
during Ocarina the sword was originally
forged by the goddess as the goddess
sword and they later reforged as the
Master Sword with the help of the sages
the goddess imbued the blade with feet
who's kind of like a spiritual avatar
for her power
she's like a humanoid spirit
representation of the goddess and gives
you tips as you complete your quest in
the game just like other items Skyward
Sword deepened the lore about the Master
Sword and this really awesome way to it
incorporates this dark version of the
sword wielded by demise it's implied
that the goddess and the sages forged
the goddess and the master swords as a
result of demise creating his own
version of the sword it's a very chicken
and the egg type of argument that gets
even more complicated when the game
incorporates time travel and even though
the hero's bow and the light arrows are
probably the most important items in the
game at least in the franchise I still
think that the Master Sword is the most
identifiable symbol of the game just
because of Arthurian myth and Excalibur
but now it's your turn let me know in
the comments below what is your favorite
zelda game and do you plan to buy Zelda
Wii U whenever it comes out next year in
related news I'm gonna be doing a couple
more lore videos on this channel so be
sure to leave me suggestions for what to
do after that I'm just gonna move them
to my game channel of Charlie's dreams
but right now click here to watch the
geek and sundry actually build the
heroes bow it's actually really really
cool and click here to watch all my
other lore videos thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
hi vice
you